[Music starts] [Audio Description - not captioned]
[Jeremy Weiss, PhD, MD] I lead the CHARM lab.
It's the Care Health And Reasoning Machine
Lab. And we develop machine learning tools
to better utilize electronic health records
data for patient characterization and for
risk assessment.
Part of my work focuses on longitudinal data
that comes from electronic health records
so that we can do forecasting, so that we
can know a patient's risk for particular sequelae
of disease forward in time, or we can at least
estimate it or predict it.
Another part of my work focuses on Equitable
Risk Assessments so that the models that we
develop have performance characteristics across
different subgroups
that may be of interest.
We don't want the models to underperform in
any particular subgroup.
A third line of work is to better understand
electronic health records data because electronic
health records data are a little bit different
than other types of clinical data
in that they're passively collected.
They're collected by indication as in the
provider has to seek out that information
for it to be entered into the electronic health
record.
Whether or not something is there is makes
the data incomplete.
Not every patient is going to have every measurement
collected.
And so, we try to understand how do we build
models that capture this type of data irregularity
and be able to use it for prediction and for
characterization purposes.
I think that better healthcare going forward
is data-based policy, data-based healthcare.
And that's why we need to develop tools and
methods that help utilize that data the best
we can so that we can make the most informed
decisions for patients.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]